sno h2o in its coolest form
drones the coolest thing in the sky
we've seen epic use of both over the
years but never at the same time snow mg
this is awesome
Wow snow drones total GameChanger when
we built our biggest drone we kept in
mind that we would want to to be able to
lift a person if we take propellers too
big it might not be stable enough if we
take the propellers too small it might
take too much power and it won't fly
long how is this drone strong enough to
tow caspere's at 40 miles an hour
normally drones are just for lifting
themselves or lifting something up into
the air but in this case castor is using
the drone to pull them forward this
relies on two things the drone producing
enough force and the angled flying
position there are four 26 inch or 66
centimeter propellers mounted on a
cross-shaped framework the propellers
accelerate air behind them delivering a
huge thrust
that's 88 pounds or 40 kilograms thrust
is the force that keeps the drone in the
air and propels it forward
the drone needs to tilt vertically and
there's a point that he gets the maximum
falling force that's when the drones
tilted as far forward as it can get but
still has enough lift to keep itself in
the air
the proportion of thrust working in
caspere's direction is more than enough
to overcome its weight and pull him
along the snow
drone boarding with a snowboard it was
fun the pool is really strong
it's absolutely enough to to carve and
do some flatland tricks and and you can
use the land where you wouldn't be able
to snowboard like before and when the
snow melts who cares
drone boarding stays cool in any weather
[Music]
Oh